Congratulations on finishing lesson three. Here we learned that it's important
to take a close look at the individual variables in your data
set. To understand the types of values they take on, what
their distributions look like, and whether there are missing values or outliers.
>> We did all this in part by using histograms, box plots, and frequency
polygons, which are some of the most
basic and important tools for visualizing and
understanding individual variables. We also made adjustments to these
plots. For example, we changed the limits on some
of our axes. We adjusted the bin width on
our histograms. And we transformed variables either logarithmically or
turned them into binaries to uncover hidden patterns in
the data. These are some of the main conclusions
that we had, and, maybe you have more. We
encourage you to share your ideas in the discussion
forum, and we'll see you again in lesson
four, where we explore the relationship between two variables.